mit Stahl machen sie ihre
Geschäfte der Gründer August tüssen
stampft ein Imperium aus dem
Boden sein Sohn wird zu einem
Steigbügelhalter der
Nationalsozialisten als Fritz tüssen mit
dem Regime bricht sperrt in Hitler ins
Konzentrationslager
doch das Unternehmen lebt
weiter die Erben adelt unermesslicher
Reichtum als bedeutendster Kunstsammler
seiner Zeit setzt sich Hans-Heinrich
tüssen borne Mist ein
Denkmal
tüssen der Name ist bis heute ein
Mythos
[Musik]
ein Haus mit einem Kilometer
Seegrundstück die Villa favorita in
Lugano einst Residenz von Hans Heinrich
tüssen borne
m hier lebte eine internationale
Patchwork Familie im High
[Musik]
soci stecke als irgendwo anders auf der
Welt das war wunderbar als Kind und dann
diese riesenerrasse wo wir immer mit
unserem Vater Z Mittagessen saßen und
mein Vater hat dann immer den Schlüssel
zur Galerie gezückt und gefragt möchte
jemand die Galerie sehen es war
ausgeschlossen zu sagen nein ich habe
Kopfschmerzen dann wäre er beleidigt
gewesen und hätte nie wieder gefragt
darum sagten wir ja
bitte he wie Hans Heinrich genannt wird
ist Herr über ein gigantisches
industrieimperium seine Leidenschaft
gehörte
Kunst er war süchtig nach Kunst jedes
Jahr hatte er sich am 1 Januar aufs Neue
vorgenommen keine Bilder mehr zu kaufen
spätestens am 6 oder 7 Januar hatte er
seine guten Vorsätze aber schon wieder
überbaut
geworfen der tüssenerbe besitzt die
bedeutendste private Kunstsammlung der
Welt er liebt es seine Bilder in der
Villa favorita auszustellen auch für die
Öffentlichkeit in fünfter Ehe heiratet
heiniy tüssen die Spanierin Carmen
Servera genannt Tita bin ich zu der
Party
eingeladen die ehemalige Miss Spanien
ist
Filmschauspielerin Anfang der 80er
begegnet sie dem 22 Jahre älteren
Multimilliardär ich habe sie
kennengelernt als durchaus charmante
Frau als Frau die die ihren Weg gegangen
ist und zwar mit aller Macht die ja aus
bescheidenen Verhältnissen gekommen ist
und dann irgendwie den Jackpot geknackt
hat und plötzlich hat sie gemerkt dieser
Mann ist auch schon älter und er liebt
mich und jetzt werde ich mal zeigen was
eine Harke ist nicht der Beginn einer
verhängnisvollen Affäre tietta will ran
an die Milliarden ihres Mannes dafür
muss sie einen Keil treiben zwischen
heiny tüssen und seine
Kinder
sie hat ihn aufgehetzt gegen alles und
jeden das ging so weit dass wir unseren
Vater nicht mehr sehen durften es liegt
auf der Hand dass diese Frau
manipulierte was und wo sie nur
konnte
1997 hat sie ihn soweit hey tüsen
verklagt seine Kinder für die er eine
familientreuhand mit Sitz in Monaco
gegründet hatte es geht um das Erbe von
rund 200 Unternehmen in mehr als 20
Länder ein Großteil des Vermögens war ja
in steuergünstigen Ländern nicht auf den
cens und weiß der Teufel wo überall
nicht und das alleine auch erstmal alles
wieder zu zählen zusammenzurechnen sind
es 7 Milliarden oder 9 Milliarden oder
doch nur 5
Milliarden der Fall tüssen gegen tüssen
Höhepunkt eines traurigen zerwirfnises
dass nur eine Gewinnerin
kennt ich bin nicht wütend auf sie aber
verzeihen
die Urquelle des geldsprudels liegt in
Duisburg hamorn vor 120 Jahren beginnt
hier die Geschichte des
tüssenkonzerns August tüssen kauft sich
heimlich die Aktienmehrheit an einem
Steinkohlebergwerk
untertage wird Kohle gefördert übertage
baut er ein Stahl und Walzwerk das
integrierte Hüttenwerk die Idee von
Augustus
August süsen hatte die Zielsetzung an
Massenprodukt Stahl in gebalzer Form zu
machen mit niedrigsten Kosten und für
jeder Mann verfügbar er hat die
Grundidee gehabt die letzten Endes zum
automobilblech geführt hat und am Ende
konnte august auf eine riesige
unternehmerische Errungenschaft blicken
und seine Hütte ist heute noch die
leistungsfähigste Hütte von ganz Europa
augustüsen schafft ein Imperium das v
bis zum Fertigprodukt reicht für Stahl
und Eisen braucht er Kohle Erd und
Wasser er kauft Zechen Erzgruben und
Wasserwerke für die Finanzierung seiner
Unternehmen kann er auf seine Familie
zurückgreifen Bruder Josef wird
Mitgesellschafter für den Transport
seiner Produkte betreibt er
Handelsgesellschaften tüssen wird zu
einem Synonym für Schwerindustrie von
weltr ist der Inbegriff eines
industriepioniers er hat die deutsche
Wirtschaftsgeschichte geprägt wie
vergleichsweise die grups oder die Famil
Siemens oder Amerika die rockefellerers
oder Henry
Ford für viele Unternehmer ist das
Zeitalter der Industrialisierung ein
goldenes auguston war ein äußerst
sparsamer Mann der auch mir immer mit
der Straßenbahn gefahren ist und da gab
es in der Straßenbahn sogenannte
zahlgrenz
und da ist er eigentlich nicht bis nach
Hause gefahren sondern ist immer eine
Station früher ausgestiegen weil da die
zahlgrenze war und da hätte da
vielleicht den Groschen mehr bezahlen
müssen nur einen Luxus gönnt er sich die
Skulpturen des berühmtesten Bildhauers
der
Jahrhundertwende sben marmorplastiken
kauft augustüsen bei augü
[Musik]
Roda ich war er gar nicht an Kunst
interessiert an den Wänden von Schloss
Landsberg hingen nur Kopien
niederländischer Maler dabei hätte er
sich ohne weiteres die originale leisten
können Schloss Landberg auf den ruhhöhen
vor Essen der Wohnsitz von
augustüssen seit 1872 ist er mit Hedwig
Pelzer einer unternehmertochter
verheiratet doch glücklich werden die
Eheleute ihres Wohlstandes
nicht es bestand wohl von Anfang an ein
gewisser Gegensatz der sich nachher dann
auch wirklich zur Krise ausweitete
zwischen seinem Familienleben und seinem
firmenleben er war auch recht unduldsam
in mancher Hinsicht was sich sicherl am
F seiner Frau ausgewirkt hat die
erwartet hatte dass er sich als Ehegatte
mehr um sie
kümmerte nach 13 Jahren lässt sich das
Paar scheiden die leidragenden sind die
Kinder der Erstgeborene Fritz August
Junior Sohn Heinrich und Tochter
Hedwig es gab dann eigentlich im Grund
kein Familienleben mehr der Vater war
ständig in der Firma od auf Reisen die
Kinder wurden also von einer Erzieherin
betreut haben aber offensichtlich sehr
unter dem Abhandenkommen der Mutter
gelitten besonders Fritz Fritz soll als
Kronprinz die Nachfolge im Unternehmen
antreten der Vater verlangt
Höchstleistungen und ist mit seinem Sohn
stets
unzufrieden sein sie mal Kind eines
Vaters wie August tüssen es ist fast
nicht zu bewältigen solche Erwartungen
zu
erfüllen dabei hat Fritz alle
Voraussetzungen für die Nachfolge
erfüllt er studierte Eisenhüttenkunde
und Maschinenbau im Inn und Ausland
gewürdigt wird das vom Vater
nicht
nur einmal wiedersetzt sich Fritz dem
gestrengen
Vater der Grund hat einen Namen Amelie
zur
helle Vater August hält die Kölnerin für
unbedeutend doch für Fritz ist Amelie
die Liebe seines Lebens später erinnert
er sich damals gab es noch tanzkarten
ich schrieb meinen Namen bei allen ihren
Tänzen ein sie war zufrieden und ich
glücklich fritz hat diese Ehe gesucht
als Hafen und er hat an ihr
festgehalten unter allen Umständen und
allen Widrigkeiten warum kann man sich
leicht erklären weil er in dieser Ehe
das fand was er zu Hause nicht
hatte nach neun Ehejahren wird ihr
einziges Kind geboren
Anita
am 4 april
1926 stirbt augustüen als einer der
reichsten aber auch einsamsten Männer im
Alter von 83 Jahren das Imperium geht
auf seine Söhne Fritz und Heinrich über
Fritz wird das heimische Stahlgeschäft
übertragen Bruder Heinrich übernimmt in
erster Linie die ausländischen
Firmen
Heinrich heiratet die Baroness Margareta
bornistza der ungarischen
Aristokratenfamilie mangelt es an
männlichen Nachkommen Heinrich wird von
seinem Schwiegervater adoptiert und
trägt fort an den Namen tüssen borne m
Heinrich geht in die Schweiz die Villa
favorita am Luganer See wird der
Familiensitz einen Namen macht sich
Heinrich als Kunstkenner er investiert
in eine Sammlung mit Werken von der
Renaissance bis zur
Romantik die Wege von Fritz und Heinrich
hatten sich
1926 vollständig getrennt weil sie
völlig getrennte Teile des tüssen
Imperiums betreuten teilweise aus
politischen grundnden anders als Fritz
der sich als deutscher Patriot verstand
war
Heinrich im Grunde
Kosmopolit
Frühjahr
Delegationen aus aller Welt verhandeln
den Frieden von versaai auch Fritz
tüssen ist als Berater
dabei die Reparationsleistungen die
Deutschland nach dem Ersten Weltkrieg
auferlegt werden empfindet Fritz als
Tiefe Demütigung sie werden Deutschland
wirtschaftlich und politisch in eine
schwere Krise
stürzen die Geschäfte die die Firma
tüssen im Ersten Weltkrieg mit
rüstungsprodukten noch gemacht hatte
sind weggebrochen auch Geschäfte mit dem
Ausland finden nicht mehr
statt das Elend auf den Straßen bleibt
den tüsens nicht
verborgen das waren schlimme Folgen und
da war ja wirklich die Not furchtbar
groß und ich kann mich noch gut erinnern
dass meine Eltern da in Mühlheim eine
kinderspeisung organisiert haben damit
die armen Kinder wenigstens mal einmal
oder zweimal in der Woche ein warmes
Mittagessen bekam
1923 Deutschland kann die
Reparationsleistungen nicht mehr
bedienen französische Truppen besetzen
das Ruhrgebiet sie wollen die Kohle und
Koksproduktion
pfenden kein industrieller traut sich
das Wort zu ergreifen es ist Fritz
tüssen der sich stellvertretend für die
Montanindustrie den Besatzern
entgegenstellt wegen
Gehorsamsverweigerung wird er vor einem
französischen Militärgericht
angeklagt die drohende Gefängnisstrafe
wenden die ruhrarbeiter im Protest für
ihren Helden
ab Fritz Rückkehr nach Duisburg gleicht
einem
Triumphzug merkte dass er in den
politischen Bereich auf einmal da eine
Führungsfigur wurde was er
vermutlicherweise gar nicht erwartet
hatte und das hat ihn offensichtlich
enorm motiviert weil da endlich mal
sozusagen er anerkannt
wurde in der jungen Weimarer Republik
kämpene Kräfte von Anfang an nicht immer
nur mit demokratischen
Mitteln von den Verheißungen der
aufkeimenden ultrarechten Bewegung
verspricht sich auch Fritz tüssen
viel fritz tüssen war ja sehr stark vom
von der Angst auch befallen Deutschland
könnte kommunistisch werden mit Hitler
hatte er bis dahin nicht sehr viel am
Hut gehabt er hatte ihn
1923 in München in Anwesenheit von
General ludendorf kennengelernt der war
in mehrere Hitler Kundgebungen gegangen
war sehr angetan von Hitlers
rhetorischer und agitatorischer
Gabe 100000 Goldmark stellt Fritz tüssen
general ludendorf 1923 zur Verfügung der
paktiert mit dem Jungen Hitler es geht
um einen
Putsch die Machtübernahme in München
scheitert den alisten bleib tüssen aber
verbunden nicht nur beruflich sondern
auch
privat Mülheim an der Ruhe Privatfilme
zeigen das familienedül der
tüssens Tochter Anita lernt
[Musik]
Autofahren es ist ein sorgloses Leben
das Fritz und Amelie
genießen eine besondere Freundschaft
verbindet die tüssens mit Hermann Göring
einem gernesehenen Gast es heißt Fritz
habe Göring gar als potentiellen Ehemann
für seine Tochter Anita vorgesehen
tüssen unterstützt den
Nationalsozialisten auch finanziell
damit der sich in gehobenen Kreisen
angemessen bewegen kann zum einen hat
Göring auf diese Weise Zugang zur
reinischwestfelischen Industrie denn er
kam auf diese Weise über Fritz tüssen
auch mit anderen Magnaten des
Ruhrgebietes in Kontakt zum zweiten war
Fritz tüssen
bekanntermaßen ein großzügiger
Förderer 26 januar
1932 ein schicksalhafter Tag für Fritz
tüssen tüssen lädt Hitler ein vor dem
Düsseldorfer Industrieclub zu sprechen
600 Wirtschaftsführer sind
anwesend dunkler Anzug weißes Hemd kein
Parteiabzeichen Hitler weiß um die
Wirkung seines Erscheinens denn er will
Spenden die er bald bekommt nicht nur
von
tüssen ein Jahr später ist der Diktator
an der Macht im Hause tüssen ist die
Naziregierung willkommen in ihrem Namen
will Fritz für eine gerechtere
Wirtschaftsordnung
sorgen
[Musik]
Fritz tüssen fühlte sich für sein
Eintreten für die Nazis dadurch belohnt
dass man ihm die höchste Autorität in
allen Wirtschaftsfragen Zumas es war
eine groteske Verkennung der der
Umstände als einer der mchtigsten
industriellen bekommt tüssen einen Sitz
im Reichstag und wird zum Preußischen
Staatsrat ernannt doch zu melden hatte
nicht
viel im Sommer 1934 zeigt das
sein wahres
Gesicht Chef Ernst röm wird verhaftet
abgesetzt und umgebracht den Mord
verteidigt Hitler sogar
öffentlichien nach
ewigich Eiser Gesetz in dieser Stunde
war ich verantwortlich für
dastion
und tüssen wen er da unterstützt
hat das war für tüssen ein
fürchterliches Erlebnis dass die Partei
und der Mann für die er sich stark
gemacht hat ein solches Verbrechen
ausgeführt hatten und später kam dann
zusätzlich sein deutliches Gespür dafür
dass Hitler auf einen Krieg zusteuern
würde was sich eben zeigte an der
Aufrüstung die er ja nun als
Aufsichtsratsvorsitzender der
Vereinigten Stahlwerke hautnah
beobachten
konnte seit 19 6 ist die Firma tüssen in
den vereinigten Stahlwerken
aufgegangen als größter Anteilseigner an
dem Zusammenschluss der Montanindustrie
übernimmt Fritz den
Aufsichtsratsvorsitz mit dem laufenden
Geschäft hat er kaum etwas zu
tun was aber mit dem vielen Stahl
passiert das wissen die Unternehmer
freilich sie liefern die Vorprodukte für
die Waffen die das Deutsche Reich
bestellt
[Musik]
die Hochzeit von Tochter Anita mit einem
ungarischen Grafen im Sommer
1936 wird zum Politikum neben
industriellen und Aristokraten sind vor
allem katholische würdäger geladen und
kaum ein
Nazi bei der Hochzeit von der Anita das
war
1936 da waren wir als Jungens mit meiner
Mutter da und das war eine mammuochzeit
im Haus in Speldorf dieses Haus ist ja
an sich schon sehr groß und da waren
dann auch riesen Zelte aufgebaut ich
weiß nicht wie viel Leute das waren aber
jedenfalls war alles davon Rang und
Namen nur keine politische Prominenz
tüssen stenkert heißt es in Berlin mit
Protestbriefen gegen die Übergriffe der
Nazis auf katholische Einrichtungen hat
es sich der industrielle mit dem Regime
verscherzt
persönliche Freunde von tüssen werden
unter den Nazis zu verfolgten wie die
jüdische Bankiersfamilie
hirschland ich weiß von einem Mitglied
der Familie hirschland dass Fritz tüssen
im Jahre
1936 mit Simon hirschland hier im
Industrieclub im Restaurant aufgetreten
ist in aller Öffentlichkeit um eine
Demonstration die natürlich gegen die
nsdp gerichtet war zu
leisten
Novemberpogrom später erinnert sich
tüsen als am 9 November in feigster und
brutalsterweise die Juden geplündert und
gemartert und ihre Gotteshäuser in ganz
Deutschland zerstört wurden habe ich
wiederum Protest eingelegt alles ohne
Erfolg jetzt bricht tüsen endgültig mit
dem Regime als der industrielle im
Sommer 39 zu einer außerordentlichen
Reichstagssitzung nach Berlin zitiert
wird ahnt er was die Stunde
schlägt er ist in Badgastein und
telegrafiert an Göring ich bin
gegenkrieg am Tag darauf fällt die
deutsche Wehrmacht in Polen
[Musik]
ein
als die Meldung über den Rundfunk kam
dass Deutschland Polen angegriffen habe
wusste tüssen oder ahnte tüssen dass er
bei seiner Rückkehr mit dem Schlimmsten
würde rechnen müssen nämlich mit der
Liquidierung so wie es den Leuten in der
römaffäre wiederfahren
sei Fritz flieht mit seiner Familie über
die Schweiz nach
Frankreich die Flucht des einstigen
nazönners ist im Ausland eine
[Musik]
Sensation aus dem Exil will Fritz die
Öffentlichkeit wachrüteln er schreibt
Briefe an Göring und an Hitler mein
einziger Fehler ist es dass ich an Sie
unserenhrer Adolf Hitler dieeg
dieonenüetb stmord ihre neue Politik
Hitler treibt Deutschland in den
Abgrund die Provokationen des
abtrünnigen bleiben nicht ohne Folgen
Fritz und Amelie wird die
Staatsbürgerschaft aberkannt das
Vermögen der gesamten Familie wird
beschlagnahmt und einem NS Treuhänder
übergeben seine Tochter Anita ihren Mann
und enkeleder lä tüsen in Sicherheit
bringen das Ziel
[Musik]
Fritz und Amelie wollen Nachkommen doch
zuvor noch Abschied nehmen tüssens
85-jährige Mutter liegt im Sterben und
dann ist er im Frühjahr 1940 das muss
man sich vorstellen nach Brüssel gereist
um seine Mutter noch mal zu sehen und
nachdem er sie gesehen hatte hat sie
dann auch in Frieden die Augen
geschlossen auf der Rückreise wird das
Ehepaar vom deutschen Einmarsch in
Frankreich überrascht
die von den Nazis eingesetzte Regierung
liefert Fritz und Amelie an die Gestapo
aus Fritz schreibt später wir wurden in
eine Irrenanstalt bei Potzdam gebracht
kaum waren wir dort angelangt als ich zu
Göring geführt wurde der mir eröffnete
entweder Volksgerichtshof und sicheres
Todesurteil oder Gnadengesuch an Hitler
im letzteren Fall würde mir mein
Vermögen wiedergegeben und ich würde auf
der früheren Besitzung meines Vaters
interniert werden
[Musik]
doch das Gnadengesuch an Hitler lehnt
Fritz
[Musik]
ab
1943 wird tüsen in ein
Konzentrationslager eingewiesen meine
Großmutter amelie ist freiwillig
mitgegangen als ih liebte die sagte hat
mann sie muss zu stehen in allen guten
und schlechten
Zeiten die konnte ih dann wenn er
meisten brauchte konnte ihm nicht
alleine
lassen Fritz und Amelie werden zu den
sonder und sippenhäftlingen
gesperrt sie genossen besondere
Bedingungen trugen keine
Anstaltskleidung mussten nicht arbeiten
kriegten zumindest in Sachsenhausen
dasselbe essen wie die SS äh Wachleute
aber sie lebten natürlich auf einem
Gelände auf dem sie in ihren aus ihren
Baracken jederzeit mitkriegten dass
Menschen exekutiert
wurden das Schicksal von Fritz und
Amelie nicht alle in der Familie tüssen
zeigen für die Inhaftierten Mitgefühl
denn auch sie sind von der Enteignung
betroffen meine Großmutter hatte dann
dazu aufgerufen dass Familie Pakete
packen sollte und das KZ schicken sollte
und mein Vater fand das als eine
ziemliche Zumutung weil ich sagte erst
hat er uns diese ganzen Probleme
eingebrockt und jetzt sollen wir ihn
auch noch
unterstützen der Bruder von Fritz
Heinrich tüssen borneemist lebt schon
seit 1932 in der Schweiz auch er kann
oder will seinem Bruder nicht helfen den
Heinrich macht Geschäfte mit dem
Deutschen Reich ist an vielen Firmen
beteiligt wie an der Bremer Vulkan die
für den uneingeschränkten U-Bootkrieg
das Material liefert
been die waren ganz verschiedene
Person wie das Öl das Wasser und
meinemutter hat immer gesagt mach nie
Geschäfte mit
HE das Angebot von naziunterhändlern den
Bruder gegen wertvolle Gemälde
einzutauschen schlägt Heinrich aus heißt
es
später es war möglicherweise ein Tief
Unverständnis und unverhältnis dieser
beiden so ungleichen Brüder Heinrich hat
sich politisch nie engagiert und ihm
sind nach allem was man weiß die
politischen
Eskapaden seines Bruders immer
unverständlich
geblieben im April 45 stehen
amerikanische Truppen kurz vor Dachau
als die Prominenten Häftlinge aus dem
Konzentrationslager abtransportiert
werden sie sollen den Amerikanern unter
keinen Umständen in die Hände fallenon
Dachau gehen die
todesmärche Richtung Süden in diese
sagenhafte altenfestung die mussten in
jeder Sekunde damit rechnen dass Sie an
der nächsten wegesbiegung
erschossen werden durch einen
glücklichen Umstand und nur mit
Unterstützung von Wehrmachtssoldaten
werden die ssbewacher gezwungen
aufzugeben am 4 mai 45 werden Fritz und
amelit von amerikanischen Truppen
befreit er war abgemagert bis 57 kgo er
war ja in einem Zustand wo manche das
Gefühl hatten er würde es gesundheitlich
überhaupt nicht mehr
durchstehen doch mit Hilfe seiner Frau
schafft es der
71-Jährige sie war sein ein und alles
und er hielt sich an ihr fest ob er das
durchgehalten hätte wenn Amelie nicht
bei ihm gewesen wäre weiß ich
nicht
noch ist die Odyssee für Fritz tüssen
nicht beendet als früher Förderer
Hitlers prüft die alliierte Justiz nun
die Schwere seiner
Schuld ja natürlich ist es angemessen
wenn es einen Tatverdacht gibt dann muss
das ermittelt werden dass gegen Fritz
Tissen ein
Entnazifizierungsverfahren in Gang
gesetetzt wurde ist vollkommen logisch
di Jahre sitzt Fritz tüssen in der Haft
der Alliierten bis das Verfahren gegen
ihn eröffnet wird der Beweisführung wird
ein Buch zugrunde gelegt das der
Journalist emer Reeves in den USA
herausgegeben hatte I paid Hitler von
Fritz
tüssen das buchprjekt das tüssen mit
Reeves 1940 angeschoben hatte wurde ohne
seine Autorisierung
fertiggestellt belastet nicht nur der
Titel den Angeklagten doch tüssen kann
glaubhaft machen dass er Hitler mit
deutlich weniger unterstützt hat als im
Buch behauptet am Ende wird er gegen
einen sühnebetrag als minder belastet
freigesprochen in dieser Zeit wird auch
Fritz nicht dem Margit verhört als
Zeugin die Tochter von Heinrich
tüssenborne m ist die Eigentümerin von
Schloss Rechnitz an der
österreichischungarischen Grenze gegen
Kriegsende war das Anwesen von der SS
requiriert
worden am 24 März 45 traf in Rechnitz
ein zwangsarbeitertransport ein 200
ungarische Juden sollten am sogenannten
Ostwall mitarbeiten einer
Verteidigungsanlage gegen die Rote
Armee am selben Abend feierten lokale
nazrößen und Gestapo aufschloss rechnet
ein kameradschaftsfest auch Hausherrin
Margit war
dabei dieses Abends trifft ein
Telefonanruf ein der sagt es ist ein
Transport von nicht
arbeitsfähigen jüdischen Arbeitern
eingetroffen und der muss laut dem Ihnen
bekannten Befehl behandelt werden und
der örtliche Gestapo Leiter Franz podzin
befolgt diesen Befehl podizin und
weitere Schergen verlassen das Fest um
die Juden zu erschießen in ihrem
verhöher bestreitet
von der Exekution Kenntnis gehabt zu
haben bis heute wurde in rechnetz und
Umgebung kein Massengrab gefunden dass
der Mord von pozin und seinen Leuten
aber begangen wurde dafür gibt es Zeugen
diese
Todesschrei wie ich das Jamel gehört
habe was
erschossen da habe ich alle fenern zu
die Ohren habe ich mir
zugestopft dass ich es nicht hören
muss it habe von dem Massaker erst am
Tag darauf erfahren gibt sie zu
Protokoll Zitat mir wurde erzählt dass
in der Nacht ca 2 km von unserem Schloss
entfernt Juden erschossen worden sein im
Jahr 2007 erschüttert ein britischer
Autor die Öffentlichkeit mit einem
Vorwurf er macht Margit
mitverantwortlich für den Mord sie habe
mitgeschossen die deutsche Presse legt
nach die tüssentochter wird zur
Gastgeberin der der Hölle zu einer
Blutgräfin die judenerschießung als
Partyspaß doch Fachleute
wiedersprechen das sind keine seriösen
Recherchen das Erschießen der Opfer ist
Sache
uniformierter Hoheitsträger der nsdp der
Wehrmacht man teilt nicht das ist
nirgendwo vorgekommen dass man jetzt
beliebig äh Zivilisten Waffen austeilt
und sagt schießt jetzt hier die
jüdischen Zwangsarbeiter oder die KZ
Leute
nieder welche Schuld trifft die Tochter
Heinrich tüssenborne mzas
wirklich es fehlen letztgültige Aussagen
dazu wie viel sie von dem Geschehen
mitbekommen hat aber die These
dass der Mord das als Belustigung und
Höhepunkt dieses Festes vorgesehen war
möchte ich von der Hand
weisen kqu hatte das Massaker von
rechnetz für Margit keine ihre Nähe zu
den Mördern steht aber außer Frage wenn
man sich mit Mördern zum Abendessen
hinsetzt dann darf man sich nicht
wundern wenn man eines Tages plötzlich
neben einem rauchenden Gewehr
steht in den Nachkriegsjahren verfügen
die Alliierten eine demontagepolitik sie
wollen Deutschland
endindustrialisieren auch der tüssensche
Industriekomplex soll zerlegt werden um
die Sieger mit den abgebauten zu
entschädigen Fritz tüssen bleibt
weiterhin
enteignet nichts hält ihn mehr in
Deutschland hat die Lust am Leben
verloren nach 7 Jahr Haft kommt man zu
einer
Depression war nicht eine sichtbare
Depression hat drin
gehabt im Januar 1950 Reisen Fritz und
Amelie zu ihrer Tochter und ihren Enkeln
nach Argentinien dann kam er Schiff an
und haben uns geküsst und umt und so
weiter ich glaube er war glücklich die
Familie zu sehen aber war ein trauriger
Mann nach den ganzen Sachen die passiert
sind die Restitution seines Vermögen
wird Fritz tüssen nicht mehr
erleben am 8 februar 1951 stirbt er im
Alter von 77
[Musik]
Jahren
Anfang der 50er Jahre erstrahlt das
tüssenwerk in neuem
[Musik]
Glanz Bundeskanzler Konrad Adenauer
kommt
1955 zu Besuch nach Duisburg er hatte
die politische Hilfestellung für den
Wiederaufbau geleistet und ich dachte
zurück an seinen Sohn den Verstorbenen
frit auf Wunsch des Kanzlers rufen die
Erbinnen eine Stiftung zur Förderung der
Wissenschaft ins Leben Z ihres Vermögens
bringen Sie dafür
auf hiervon stiftet Frau Amel durch die
fritzissen Vermögensverwaltung 75
Millionen und ihre Tochter Gräfin si
durch die Tien AG für Beteiligung 25
million die Unternehmensleitung
überlassen die beiden Erbinnen Managern
die aus der Duisburger tüssenhütte einen
Global Player
machen die nachfage nach und
Qualitätsstahl ist groß die Produktion
bei tüssen
boomt die Wirtschaftswunderjahre waren
für die tüssen Manager wie eine zweite
industrielle
Revolution diese zweite industrielle
Revolution hat uns dann zum absoluten
spitzenwohlstand verholfen dieses ist
nur möglich gewesen weil das ungeheure
Erbe das Fritz tüssen uns hinterlassen
hat uns Unglaub möglichkeiten geben
unglaubliche
[Musik]
Gestaltungsmöglichkeiten hat auch der
Sohn von Heinrich tüssenborne m geerbt
Hans Heinrich genannt
[Gelächter]
heiniereit in drit Ehe verheiratet mit
einem
britischenomodell
das Heim der jungen
[Musik]
Familie doch zu Frauen hat he ein eher
kompliziertes
Verhältnis mein Vater wurde von einem
Kindermädchen groß gezogen das bei
seinem 18 Geburtstag entlassen wurde
aber sie war nicht bloß ein
Kindermädchen sie war wie eine zweite
Mutter für ihn ein menschliches Wesen
das von einem auf den anderen Ruhestand
geschickt wurde nach dem Motto wir
brauchen dich nicht mehr sie hat sich
daraufhin das Leben genommen weil man
sie von ihrem Sohn weggerissen
[Musik]
hatte mein Vater hatte panische Angst
davor einsam und Arm zu
sterben das hat ihn sein Leben lang
verfolgt das macht he zu einem rastlosen
Geschäftsmann er Hersteller von Pumpen
und
eiersortiermaschinen auch
bankenbrauereien und sogar eine
ölhandelsfirma zählen zu der Milliarden
schweren
Unternehmensgruppe also er hat
eigentlich in allen Bereichen sehr
erfolgreich gewirkt er hat seine
Geschwister ganz ruhig und ohne jliches
Aufhebens abgefunden er hat die Sammlung
seines
Vaters zum Teil wieder her aufgebaut
dadurch dass er seinen Geschwistern Teil
der Bilder abgekauft hat er hat
offensichtlich unternehmerisch guten
Erfolg gehabt mit ausgeprägtem
Kunstverstand baut tüssen die väterliche
Sammlung
aus he tsson war der bedeutendste
Kunstsammler der Welt ein Sammler dieser
Größenordnung bestimmt auch den
Geschmack der Zeit ohne Frage sein
Interesse galt vor allem den deutschen
Expressionisten deren Marktpreise hat er
damit weltweit
beeinflusst
Nolde Heckel Kirchner die Nachfrage nach
deutschen Expressionisten ist vor allem
he tüssen zu
verdanken bekannt wird er aber nicht nur
als Sammler großer Meister sondern auch
schöner
Frauen einmal sagte er wenn ich die Wahl
hätte zwischen einer schönen Frau und
einem Bild würde ich mich für das Bild
entscheiden das kann ich mir an die Wand
hängen und es gibt keine
Wiederworte doch mit guten Vorsätzen tut
sich schwer in fünfter Ehe heiratet er
Tita die Witwe von Lex Barker es wird
stiller um den Casanova als Tita sein
Leben in die Hand nimmt hey tüssen hat
gesagt die liebt mich wegen meiner
selbstwillen der ist es ganz egal ob ich
Milliarden
habe ist eine schöne Einstellung von ihm
die würde mich auch lieben wenn ich
helmut Müller hieße und aus der Bäckerei
von neben ankäme
1987 will der 66-Jährige sein
Vermächtnis Regeln und entscheidet sich
seine einzigartige Sammlung der
Öffentlichkeit zu stiften die wird auf
rund 2 Milliarden demmark geschätzt den
Zuschlag erhält Spanien das Heimatland
seiner Frau 1992 öffnet das Museum
tüsenborne mistza in Madrid eine der
größten Attraktionen in der spanischen
Hauptstadt auch für den Fortbestand des
Firmenimperiums hatte Hein schon früh
gesorgt 193
gründete er für seine Kinder eine
Treuhandgesellschaft mit Sitz in
Monaco die Leitung übertrug er seinem
ältesten Sohn Georg
Heinrich er dürfte keinen Zweifel daran
gehabt haben dass die die beiden
Bereiche seiner persönlichen Aktivität
der unternehmerische und der
sammlerische sich jeweils in guter fon
befanden wenige Jahre später ist tüssen
borne mista nach mehreren Schlaganfällen
von Krankheit
[Musik]
gezeichnet jetzt übernimmt Ehefrau Tita
das
Regiment die Geschäfte der
familientreuhand die der Sohn führt
laufen gut aber auch nicht immer die
vereinbarten Ausschüttungen können
zeitweise nicht in volollle Höhe an den
Vater ausbezahlt werden da holt Tita zum
Schlag aus Georg s alles wegehmen Geld
und Firmen klagt sie in der Presse im
Januar 1997 reichen heinys Anwälte Klage
gegen die familientreuhand
[Musik]
ein aus Angst die Kontrolle zu verlieren
lie niemanden mehr in seine
Nähe auch mich nicht das brach mir das
Herz sie
meiner lassen werde und sich niemand von
uns Kindern mehr für ihn interessieren
würde was überhaupt nicht
stimmte fast zwei Jahre wird auf den
Bermudas prozessiert für die Anwälte ist
der Erbstreit eine
Goldgrube für die Presse
auch und habe ich gesagt he ich kann mir
das vorstellen wie ihnen ist sie klagen
gegen ihren eigenen Sohn und dann fing
an hören sie auf damit hören sie auf
damit es hat mich bereits jetzt das war
aber gerade erst am Anfang dieser ganzen
Auseinandersetzung 100 Millionen Dollar
Anwaltskosten gekostet und ich gehe mal
davon aus mein Sohn Heini genauso viel
es geht um too much money zu viel Geld
dem Richter Platz 2001 der Kragen die
Beträge die in diesem Fall verschwendet
würden seien ausgesprochen obs zön klagt
er und legt sein Amt nieder das
Verfahren bleibt
stecken
uns war klar dass ihn der ewige Streit
umbringen würde darum wollten wir
unbedingt zu einer Einigung kommen unser
Vater sollte in Frieden sterben und
wissen dass wir am Ende doch
zusammenhalten die Kinder geben nach
2002 kommt es zu einer
außergerichtlichen Einigung die Firma
bleibt bei Sohn Georg Heinrich der
Familiensitz und vieles mehr
[Musik]
wirdespren glücklich und alle wollen es
haben alle streiten sich darüber alle
kämpfen
darüber auch für die Nachfahren von
Fritz tüssen die in Argentinien Leben
bleibt das Erbe eine Bürde der Fluch des
Goldes da kann man Bücher schreiben ich
habe auch Probleme mit meiner Familie
meinen Kindern sprechen mich überhaupt
nicht habe Prozesse
laufen ganze Leben
lang 195 scheiden mit den sich tüsens
die letzten Nachfahren des Gründers aus
dem
Unternehmen heute ist das Lebenswerk von
August tüssen nach der Fusion mit krup
ein weltweitt tätiger Technologie und
werkstoffkonzern mit über 170 000
Mitarbeitern der letzte Enkel des
Gründers Heini tüssenborne m stirbt im
April 2002 wenige Wochen nach dem dem
Ende des
Familienstreits mit dem Tod des großen
MZ fällt der Vorhang über das
tüssenschauspiel als Heini in der Gruft
von Schloss Landsberg beigesetzt wird
findet er neben seinen Ahnen die letzte
Ruhe es war der Wille von augustüssen
das Schloss Landsberg der Familie
erhalten bleibt als Stammsitz seiner
Dynastie doch sein
hat die Dynastie zerrissen erst im Tod
sind sie wieder
[Musik]
vereint